with the exception of infinity war Clint
Barton aka Hawkeye has been a mainstay
of the avengers gatherings an
introduction of his wife Laura in age of
Ultron proved the Earth's Mightiest
Heroes could have a home life as well if
the kind supportive mrs. Barton looks
familiar it's probably because you've
almost definitely seen Linda Cardellini
in something before the actress has been
active in Hollywood for more than two
decades and has racked up some
impressive credits along the way from
roles and children's favorites of the
late 90s to ptb appearances here's where
you may have seen Cardellini before TGIF
after enjoying a breakout role in ABC's
kid thriller series bone Chile's
Cardellini spent a great deal of her
early career in the kid centric
television circuits she enjoyed cameo
roles in TGIF shows like step by step
and Boy Meets World and also made
appearances on 3rd Rock from the Sun and
the clueless small screen series Boy
Meets World was significant for her
because it was the first role for which
she was recognized Alton about albeit
for all the wrong reasons as she told
The AV Club I was at my hometown
carnival and about eight kids run up to
me they couldn't have been older than
eight years old and yelled homewrecker
hey those team Topanga fans can be
intense good burger Cardellini silver
screen breakthrough came by way of
Nickelodeon's good burger a bizarre
fast-food film based on a regular sketch
from the TV networks all that in the
movie she appears as Heather a young
woman in a mental institute whose
history may or may not include breaking
into a zoo to free the Kangaroos of the
behest of space aliens and a psychopath
a man should later reunite of the film
stars Kenan Thompson and Kel Mitchell
for an episode of their buddy comedy
Kenan & Kel strange land shortly after
the advent of the AOL chat room came
strange land a feature-length PSA about
the dangers of meeting strangers online
although the technology is now outmoded
the movies message is status relevant as
today as it was back then and Cardellini
stern as a girl is abducted after going
to the fake party of a guy she met on
the Internet still produces a lot of
terror
freaks and geeks after owning several
regular television spots in series I did
at last Cardellini landed a central role
of Lindsay Weir in NBC's freaks and
geeks the show featured her as an
awkward high schooler who decides
make friends as some of the less
academically inclined members of the
student population much to her parents
disappointment although it was canceled
after the first season it since become a
cult favorite I loved the show I
continued to love it like I feel so
lucky it's one of how can you not be
proud of it it may not have offered a
long time job security at the time but
the series does offer her one heck of a
highlight reel as the series continues
to draw in new fans Legally Blonde
Cardellini z-- appearance in this
romantic comedy taught us all about the
unexpected legal importance of a solid
haircare regimen in Legally Blonde
Cardellini takes the stand as a daughter
of a murdered millionaire to testify
against the client of Reese
Witherspoon's Elle Woods card Elena's
role might have been small but it was
hardly superfluous when it comes to the
overarching plot of Elle Woods overnight
to sense a master litigator you however
had time to hide the gun didn't you
chutney after you shot your father I
didn't mean to shoot him scooby-doo
although the scooby-doo films didn't
quite make her a household name they did
align her with some very popular teen
styles of the time including Freddie
Prinze jr. Sarah Michelle Gellar and
Matthew Lillard and Ted Turner's Velma
has some purposefully provocative
moments that are still worth discussing
thanks to her thick glasses and unusual
hair in the first film her face wasn't
exactly getting seared into audience's
memories during the movie but after her
big makeover seen in scooby-doo -
monsters unleash her true appearance
became much less of a mystery for
moviegoers Brokeback Mountain podoleni
also had a brief role in angley's
Brokeback Mountain as Cassie Cartwright
a small-town waitress who takes a shine
to Heath Ledger's Ennis Del Mar not
knowing he's still holding a candle for
Jake Gyllenhaal's Jack twists Cardellini
admitted that our interest in the small
role first stem from admiration for the
director and screenwriter
she told the a/v Club I'm a huge Angley
fan and a huge Larry McMurtry fan that
script is so beautiful I remember
spending 45 minutes auditioning and
thinking I may not get this part but it
doesn't matter because I just spent 45
minutes getting directed by Angley when
I got the parts it was really a gift and
privilege er Cardellini really got to
show off a flare for the dramatic with a
long-standing role on NBC's er as Sam
taggart a nurse who was both a
recovering alcoholic and the single
mother she played the character for six
seasons enjoying everything from
unstable exes to a hostage situation at
the hospital to an exploding ambulance
although she was able to do other
projects during her five season run on
the show she's called the experience of
being on the series a marathon and
didn't commit to doing any regular TV
work other than voice roles an animated
series for the better part of a decade
afterward returned one of cuddly knees
post er passion projects was a small
film called return which featured her in
the lead is a war veteran returning home
to her family
and finding that although she's wanted
nothing more than to be with them again
she doesn't recognize or feel recognized
by our old world the film was one of the
first that would feature Cardellini in
every scene and while it might not have
been a box-office smash it was one of
several well reviewed projects that
would help earn the actress some serious
indie cred Mad Men
among the many prestige TV shows to take
hold of Hollywood in recent years AMC's
Mad Men had to have the most buzzie
cameo list of all Cardellini included in
the show's sixth season she debuted in
her occuring role to sylvia rosen a
neighbor to jon Hamm's don draper she
becomes his part-time lover and
eventually full-time obsession her
appearance on the show reveals some
staggering details about his often
mysterious past for Cardellini being a
part of the award season favorite series
men that you'd have to keep a set secret
but that extra work on the home front
was worth it because she earned her
first and only Emmy nomination for a
work on the show daddy's home
Cardellini does seem particularly a home
in the comedy realm it's what made her a
good fit for a guest role on new girl
and why she was such a scene stealer in
Grandma's Boy and daddy's home and its
sequel gave the actress another chance
to play around with some other funny
people for a while namely Will Ferrell
and Mark Wahlberg in the movies she
stars as Sarah the mother of two whose
new spouse is an ideal stepfather to her
children but whose first husband is a
master returns to stir up trouble and
attempt to win back his family from the
new guy antics ensue
[Applause]
bloodline Catalina's real return to the
small screen came by way of Netflix's
bloodline as meg Rayburn the youngest in
a tumultuous family who tries and often
fails to broker peace between her
siblings she started in the series for
three seasons which gave a character
plenty of room to arc into some dark
places and Cardellini relished the
opportunity she initially joined the
series because of the talent that should
get to work with on the show I found
that working on another series gave her
the opportunity to stretch her creative
legs and away films cannot as she told
Elmo Cozine I think there are great
roles for women in television because
there is time to allow those characters
to evolve voice work in addition to
having a diverse portfolio screen
appearances Cardellini is also a
prolific voice actress she started doing
vocal work for video games before
earning a title role in the short-lived
ABC animated series the good family
should go on to do voice work for a
number of other cartoon shows including
scooby-doo mystery Incorporated out
there Regular Show and Disney's gravity
falls where your bottom line like a
rhinestone slipper / familiar voice may
make it difficult for her to make prank
calls but the ability to act off-camera
has definitely helped her pay the bills
over the years in between on-screen gigs
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your lefting
[Music]